we're asked to represent the following
function on the coordinate plane and
they give us domain and then they give
us a range a set of a set of values that
our function can take on and the way the
question has been phrased I'm assuming
they assume they're they're making us
assume that the the negative 8 maps to
the for the negative 6 maps to the 3 the
negative 4 maps to the to the negative 2
maps to 1 and the 0 maps to 0 because
you could have another function with
this exact same domain and this exact
same range where the mapping is
different we're negative 8 maps to 3 and
negative 6 maps to 4 so you could
actually this domain and this range
could be for many different functions
but when they say represent the
following function I'm assuming that
they're just assuming that they want us
to assume that they're kind of in order
the pairing so let's just graph this
function or represent it using their
terminology so let me draw some axes
here so this is the domain the
independent variable just like that
often known as the x axis or the
horizontal axis and all of our domain
all the values these are all non
positive numbers so let me give a lot
more space to quadrant 2 all of our
range or positive numbers so we're going
to be hanging out in the top-left
quadrant or quadrant 2 just like that
and the values that my domain can take
on are 0 through negative 8 and every
even negative number so it's 0 let me do
it like this so 0 is there and then we
have negative 2 negative 4 negative 6
and then we have negative 8
yes like that and then our range goes
from 0 through 4 so this is 0 then you
have 1 then you have two then you have 3
and then you have 4 so if we assume the
mapping that if we if this if you give
this function a negative 8 it's going to
map to 4 then we can plot it here so if
we take this first pair right there you
give me a negative 8 this function is
gonna give me a 4 so negative 8 4 is
that point right there
so if you imagine that this is X the x
axis this would be the f of
x-axis if we're assuming that F is this
function you give me a negative 6 I'll
give you a 3 negative 6 and 3 you give
me a negative 4 this function will pop
out a 2 negative 4 comma 2 and then you
give a negative 2 this function will pop
out a 1 F of negative 2 is 1 F of
negative 2 is 1 and then finally you
want your f of 0 is 0 so we'll just plot
it right there so that's the function
I've represented it and remember this is
I just assumed that negative 8 maps to 4
negative 6 maps to 3 but you could have
multiple functions that have this domain
and range but just the way that they
said the following function I'm assuming
this is what they want us to do